beautiful planet it's a wonderful
experience that will take every man
woman and child into space with the
astronaut crews aboard the International
Space Station I love space I love
anything that has to do with space and
it's also just a you know a love letter
to our planet it is a story that's
really a human story but it's about the
relationship of astronauts to our planet
it really does take you on our journey
to space and Bamber the beautiful planet
is is going to show people just how
fragile this planet is and just how
special it is they brought back footage
that we have never been able to capture
before and I'm excited for the world to
see that you know there can be a debate
about the changes going on earth in a
classroom but when you look back and you
see that image you get it
the earth is our life-support system it
is our only home at the moment so I
think it's important for people to see
them a movie like this which is in such
a special compelling this really
compelling way it drives the point home
I think the film will speak to everybody
I think it will speak to children it
will speak to adults and I think it will
speak to as soon as showing people all
over the world